what is up guys my name is Journal
welcome to episode 4 of 3d game
programming in Java I'm really excited
about today's tutorial because we will
hopefully actually be you know creating
a graphics thing and drawing pixels to
the screen when I say hopefully I mean
definitely I don't care this tutorial
ends up being half an hour long we will
as God is my witness we will draw pixels
today I'm going to try and make it under
20 minutes but you know we'll see I'll
stop talking and we'll start last time
we've created an array of pixels and now
we're actually going to fill that array
we're gonna draw stuff to each of those
pixels and the way we're going to do
that is we're going to make a method
called draw and we'll create an object
out of this render class and we will
also create two integers X offset and Y
offset okay and we'll create a full loop
in here I'll explain what that is in a
minute and Y is less than render dot
height that's why we created that
objective because we want to be able to
access height and stuff like that my
plus one
yeah and in here we'll create a will
create call it wipe X pixels all the Y
pixels so Y is in Y that's X that's why
Y is vertical y plus y offset okay
traditionally you would call it offs
that's sort of like a convention and
computer graphics programming that I'm
just going to call it offset I'll
explain what that is in a minute as well
first of all for loop so basically a for
loop in Java is a way of doing things
multiple times so running the same code
multiple times and the way that it works
first of all we we're creating in an
integer called Y and we're setting the
value of it to zero and we're saying as
long as the value of this is less than
this so less than height height will
actually be set from inside display or
maybe another class I'm not sure I
haven't decided yet
so don't worry about that because you
know obviously we haven't actually set a
value too high yet but as long as Y is
less than height keep doing this and
each time you do this add one to Y so
the first time it does it why well one
one will be added to Y so Y will become
one next time it does it will become two
three four blahblah until it becomes
this and then it'll stop until it big
you know until it's less than this so as
long as it's less than this it'll keep
doing this and what we're doing here is
we're pretty much creating a variable
and assigning you know y plus y offset
so that'll change obviously and the way
this works is in comm paint.net I've
already made it grew at this time so I
don't have to waste time doing that um
the way this works is we want to create
we want to fill these pixels or do we
want to draw to these pixels so as you
can imagine y equals zero let's just say
it's this pixel here y equals one it's
this pixel here so basically we'll do
that until it covers the whole height
and what we've actively done is we've
drawn we've sort of filled all these
pixels right now the next thing we need
to do is obviously you know fill the X
values as well so what you could assume
is that okay let's just do the same
thing let's create another full loop and
you know change it to X and change this
to you know obviously with and you know
X offset X X right and that would work
well it would but it's not going to give
us the the desired result because
basically what it's going to do is
you're saying okay let's do the same
thing for X so it's going to fill this
area so now we've got we've sort of got
both of these areas filled up but you
know what about this area alright
we've already we've only filled up these
two so we also need to fill all of this
area so how are we going to do that and
it's
actually pretty simple fortunately my
wake this out the other day it's well I
didn't really work it out well I did
work it out but like she'll someone's on
for ah it's yeah so basically the way
that this works is that um we're saying
okay so let's put this full loop inside
this full loop so what we're getting
here is basically for each Y pixel that
it creates let's create a bunch of X
pixels until X becomes equal to or
greater than the width
so basically when Y when y equals zero
it'll create this when y equals one
it'll create you know all these and so
you know at the end we get the whole
screen covered or basically you know the
whole size of when we might only draw
this area so rendered dot height would
be this this amount of pixels and red
adult width would be that amount of
pixels yeah so that's how that works I
won't close paint on that we might need
it later
yeah so now that we've got we've sort of
got this worked out we actually need to
fill that array so the way we're going
to do that is we're simply going to go X
pix + y pix
x width and again we don't actually need
to do anything for for height because
our height is sort of you know because
with is sort of each of these with with
you know we don't need to do anything
that height because we've sort of put
height inside of with if that makes
sense and and we're going to actually
assign that to these pixels and X plus y
times randa dot with okay fantastic by
the way if it wraps lines actually fix
this later if you go into format or and
because what it will do with the default
thing is it'll actually wrap the line
like this so the way fix that is you go
to windows window preferences
go into Java code style formatter hit
edit and you know set this to whatever
you want
I just times it by ten that should be
enough okay awesome
yeah okay so now we need to actually
render these pixels let's create a new
class for that
yeah well create a subclass well okay
don't worry about that right click new
class we'll put it inside of graphics
and we'll just call screen and extends
Randall so basically we're saying
inherit all the good stuff of random all
the stuff of render and we'll animate
will it'll create a constructor for us
automatically a super means that it's
inherit it's inheriting basically width
and height from here with the night with
the night okay so yeah what we're going
to do here is we're sort of going to
test we're going to use this in a way to
test out this code because we want to do
that by drawing pixel to the screen so
I'll create I'll create a method called
Randall
and we'll draw okay yeah well we'll draw
stuff to that in a minute and draw by
the way I'm getting from here but we
haven't actually created the object at
once so let's do that real quick first
thing I want to do is create an object
of random just gonna call a test because
we're just testing out the stuff and I'm
going to draw tests to zero to zero and
the zeros are the X offset and the y
offset and I'll tell you about offset in
a minute basically where I'm getting
these parameters from is from here so
the actual object render render so we
called in this case we have actually
called render you know test because it's
it we're just testing this out and
offset Y offset are the next two
parameters so we've set them to zero to
zero now the way that these to offset
work and is this actually going to be
really going to be really important
because I'm I'm actually going to
demonstrate this stuff later
is that if we this is y plus y offset so
it's going to be y plus whatever the
offset is so if we if we change the
offset to 5 it's going to offset that
pixel by 5 pixels makes sense we could
also call this you know X X position but
it you know it's just a convention in
graphics programming to call this some
offset so I've called it offset but yeah
it's basically just just displacing the
position of X and off-white to our
liking okay and once we do it once we've
done that we're just going to create
test equals new render and let's just
say we'll created 256 budget which is 56
so we're just creating a square of
pixels where why these numbers even work
is because if we go back to enter enter
you'll see that I actually put int width
and then type okay so we're actually
telling it what the width and height is
now so that we can actually use that in
the future run it at height we're saying
it's now 256 so do this do this 256
times
I hope that makes sense if it doesn't
kill me I'll spend another half hour
explaining it okay let's create a full
loop as well it's it's a convention
enjoyable to use white to use I sorry if
you don't have a name for it so you know
here we're sort of we've set it to Y and
X because we're sort of doing Y and X
but if we just wanted to do stuff a
bunch of times and we don't really can't
really think of a name for it then use I
that's just a convention you can name it
whatever you like and as long as I is
less than 256 x 256 could just work out
that number using a calculator but Java
can do that for us so why not
and we're just going to use okay we're
going to use something called random so
random random cause new random and
random is basically a Java utility and
it's it will it's used to generate a
stream of pseudo-random numbers
basically it's going to create a random
number for us which is good because we
want to sort of rat ran randomized like
the the pixels on the color of the
pixels and stuff like that and we need
to actually put that under super because
super needs to be first because that's
how zebra works okay random not sorry
not random what is it pixels rather test
or pixels because we're using pixels
from render test or pixels I and I is
from here so it sort of changes every
time every time we complete a loop of
this for loop random dot next int okay
fantastic
that's that's good okay that's shoot
again the thing we need to do now is
initialize that graphics adapter and
actually you know make a graphics
display out of it first of all let's get
rid of render because we've actually
changed that to a subclass which we've
called screen so screen equals new
screen width height and while I'm at it
we need to import screen of course
well yeah first of all we need to import
screen second of all we actually need to
make an object out of it so private
screen screen and yeah we're going to
use something called offered image and
we're going to call it image IMG shelf
image let's import this and the way it's
going to work is it's basically like a
graphics thing
you offered image and what are the
parameters its width height and the
color which is buffered image dot oh
thank god for eclipses little thing
otherwise I can't remember
RGB fantastic type the type int RGB red
green and blue colors again wonderful we
have color and the other thing we want
to do is actually oh yeah okay we need
to create pixels and will will create a
separate pixels private int pixels and
then we'll assign them to these pixels
in a minute to these pixels that with
the the array that we created there so
pixels equals okay we'll use something
called a data buffer int and image dot
get raster dot get data buffer don't get
up
okay so with this hmm can't be resolved
oh yeah
a clip sometimes doesn't do this
properly let's copy them into here and
we might have to manually import it I
think yes like I did the same thing this
should work
yep fantastic yeah you'll have to
manually import it so it's located in
the same amount of it's located in the
same folder is buffered image so simply
yeah change buffett image copy it and
change it to data buffer int because
that's what's called okay I think we're
done on this this front I was in this
place um yeah okay let's render it we'll
use something okay we need to initialize
something called a buffer strategy but
yes equals you get buffer strategy
that's right and a buffer strategy is
another thing we need to import and it's
like a graphics thing as well the we
need and now we actually need to you
know set we actually need to create we
need to initialize this buffer strategy
and the way we do that is okay first of
all you have to think about this render
is sort of being updated every time
because
randa is in our while running loop in
the run method so we're in but but we
only want to actually start this buffer
strategy once we don't want to start the
graphic setting multiple times we don't
want we don't want a lot of instances of
the same thing running we only want to
we only want to start buffer strategy
once so the way we do that is we go if B
is so off strategy is null okay
introduce something you double equals
lines means check if it is it sort of it
compares it is BS null if we put one is
basically assigning null to be a so it's
an assignment operator
so saying bs equals null so of course
you know what
was going to be here or this condition
is always going to be true so we've just
assigned it to that and equals with it
checks you know is it null and if it is
do this and what we want to do here is
actually create the buffer strategy and
we're going to use the parameters of
three because we want to create a
three-dimensional game if we were
creating a 2-d game we'd put two but for
this we need three and after that you
know we don't want to do that one once
so return okay next thing we'll do is
we'll create a for loop again you know I
equals 0 I is less than width times
height so again we want to create those
pixels I plus plus so so basically do
this 480 thousand times because 800 x
600 is 480 thousand okay and what we're
gonna do here is we want to assign
pixels you know with the array of I
which will change every time to what we
call that object screen just screened up
pixels as well okay I think that's
though of course when it actually use
Javas graphics graphics G equals yes
don't get draw graphics I think it's
called yeah okay we need to import this
first of all G again is just like a
convention usually an image a g dot
dispose again that's sort of like it we
have actually drawn it up do that in a
minute and be sure where to show it
what is it draw image yeah okay that's a
lot of parameters um with these are
offsets with Heights yeah yes that's
good enough I don't need any of this
okay
I think we're good one thing we actually
need to do probably is spring render and
yeah that that should work let's test it
out
yep there we go guys we have pixels yay
okay
awesome we made it in 19 minutes okay
I'm not actually going to touch any of
this make sure that you guys are
following along make sure you've copied
this code into your Eclipse or into
whatever thing you're using um and yeah
and actually before we go we'll just
take a closer look at these pixels and
just times it by 20 yeah pixels ha ha
and they're randomly generated their
color is randomly generated anyway we'll
talk about this we'll talk about even
animating this stuff and all that good
stuff tomorrow okay so make sure if
you're not already subscribed go ahead
click click subscribe so that you don't
miss a video and yeah so next time it's
gonna be really exciting we're going to
start doing some awesome stuff with
these pixels see you guys later
bye
[Music]
[Music]